All right, let's get moving.
Good morning.
Let me take a quick poll.
So, how many of you have
completed Lab 4.
Completed Lab 4?
Wow, that's great.
So, how many people have begun
Lab 4?
OK, well that's good.
I won't ask the last question.
OK so, well I hope you're
having fun with this lab.
Lab 4 was designed to be almost
like a mini-project.
And, it sort of ties together a
lot of the content of the entire
course.
And, it's not unlike the kind
of systems that people design in
industry, in systems that go
into a variety of devices like,
say, for example,
digital CD players and stuff
like that.
A lot of mixed signal stuff
goes in.
OK, so today,
I'm going to continue with our
discussion of energy and CMOS.
CMOS will be a new topic that I
will introduce.
So, the last lecture,
we spent a fair bit of time
talking about energy,
and how to compute the energy
of our inverter.
So, let me start from where I
left off, and I've given you a
couple of extra pages of notes
today just to sort of tie it to
the previous lecture.
Right now, I'm going to start
off on page three.
So, what we saw last time was
an inverter of this sort,
Vs, VIN, and we said,
let's study the situation where
this inverter was driving a load
capacitor, C.
Where did this load capacitor
come from?
Well, this inverter could be
driving one, or two,
or three, or four other larger
gates, OK?
So, this C is lumped value of
the gate capacitances of all of
those inverters.
This may also include some
component due to wiring
capacitance and stuff like that.
So, for an inverter like this,
we showed in the last lecture
that the formula for the average
power was,
so this was a static power
independent of frequency,
and this was called dynamic
power, and it had some bearing,
it's related to the frequency
at which you clocked your
circuit.
So, this was related to standby
power, and this to dynamic.
So, what I also said is that I
gave you a bunch of numbers so
you could compute the power
consumption of a chip that
included 10^8 gates,
100 million gates,
and at a frequency of 1 GHz,
and a bunch of other numbers.
C was given to be 0.1
femtofarads.
Femto is 10^-15.
So, F was 10^9.
VS was 5V, and for these
numbers, if you plonk them down
in something like this,
for 10^8 gates on a chip,
the average power would be 10^8
times these two.
So, this would be five squared,
which is 25,
divided by twice.
RL was given to be 10
kilo-ohms, so,
twice, 10^4.
And here we had CVS^2.
So, C was 10^-16,
0.1 femtofarads.
Vs^2 was 25,
and F was 10^9.
So, if you commence through the
numbers here,
what you end up getting is
something that looks like this,
10^8 times this guy here.
This is 1.25mW plus this guy
ends up being 2.5 microwatts.
So, this should come as a bit
of a shocker.
If I take 1.25mW,
and multiply that out by 10^8,
this says that each gate
suffers a standby power loss of
1.25mW.
So times 10^8,
I get 125kW,
and this guy yields 250W.
OK, the 250W is manageable.
It's still high,
and just so you don't think
that this is unreasonable,
when the Pentium 4 first came
out, it was consuming 170W of
power.
OK, you should see the heat
sinks on there.
There's actually a huge heat
sink with a fan built into the
top of the heat sink.
OK, today it's down to more
reasonable numbers like 100W and
so on, but when it came out it
was in this range.
So it's high but not
unreasonable.
But this, of course,
is totally wacko.
OK, imagine carrying a laptop
around, and the sucker is
blowing 125kW.
That'll be fun.
So, clearly there's something
wrong here.
What this is saying is that
this gate here consumes 125kW,
there are 10^8 of these on a
single chip.
OK, so we clearly have to do
something about this,
otherwise the semiconductor
industry would fail.
So, anybody have any ideas?
What do you think you might do
here?
to this inverter to make this
look better, to bring it down?
What can I do?
Anybody?
Any ideas?
What do you think?
Well, the problem is that if I
look at this 125kW,
well, there's a VS term here
and an RL term here.
So, I can increase RL.
OK, I can make RL four times or
eight times as large.
That'll bring the power down
somewhat.
Can anybody think of any
problem with increasing RL?
If I make RL really,
really large,
will I run into other problems?
Yes?
Exactly, the slowdown of the
inverter.
Remember, the rise time of the
inverter depends on how quickly
I can charge this capacitor
through RL.
So, if I make my RL really
large, I will consume less
standby power from hundreds of
kilowatts to merely tens of
kilowatts.
But my gates will run as slow
as molasses.
So, clearly that's not a
tradeoff I would like to make.
So, I can reduce my voltage to
maybe a volt.
But that just reduces it by a
factor of 25,
VS squared.
So clearly, this is not going
to work.
I have to somehow do something
else, and that will be the topic
of today's lecture.
Also, I will dwell for a moment
on this term.
So, if you look at the spec
sheet for the IBM's ASIC
processor that we handed out,
if you recall,
we talked about power
dissipation of 0.006 microwatts
per MHz per gate.
OK, now you see where this is
coming from.
Per MHz, that's because it's a
multiple of f,
the power.
Second is that it's per gate,
so this is the power per gate.
So, as I have more gates,
I just have that much more
power dissipation.
It also says power supply
voltage in the range of 0.7 to
1.3 right next to the power
expression.
So, you can see why they tell
you all of that,
because both voltage,
and the frequency,
and the number of gates come
into the power of equation.
OK, this really simple
expression here,
it's amazing how close this is
to what people use for the
dynamic power in chips.
OK, so as the next step,
what I'd like to do is,
this guy, what do we do about
that?
OK, so we've taught you to
build gates in a particular
matter, but it's a non-starter.
So, how do we get rid of static
power?
How do we get rid of static
OK, to do so,
let's build up a little bit of
intuition.
OK, so the intuition goes as
follows.
So let's say I take my
inverter.
Let me draw the circuit both on
the on state and in the off
state.
So, when VIN is high,
when VIN is high,
I get the MOSFET turning on and
has a resistance,
RON, and Vo is the output
voltage.
Similarly, when VIN is low,
so when VIN was high,
Vo was low because RON is much
less than RL.
So, this voltage was low,
while here, when VIN is low,
the MOSFET is off,
and so I have an open circuit
out here.
And because of that open
circuit, the voltage here was
going to be high because VS
would simply appear there.
So let's tailor this and see if
we can build up some intuition
as to what to do.
So, when VIN is low,
I don't have any static power
being dissipated because I don't
have a connection from VS to
ground.
OK, the current,
i, is zero.
And, VS simply appears at the
output.
The reason this is so is have a
switch here.
So when this is low,
the switch opens up and cuts
the path from power to ground.
This is a nice situation.
Here, when VIN was high,
there was no switch that turns
off.
Rather, I get a connection from
VS to ground.
OK, so think about this
situation here.
The insight here is,
just imagine if I could do the
following.
Imagine if I could somehow
magically elevate RL to be a
very, very, very large number,
if I could make this so high as
to make the power really low
only in the situation when the
input was high,
OK?
So, imagine if I could do
something like this.
Imagine I could open circuit
this guy, RON,
so when VIN was high,
if I could, instead of having
an RL here, what if somehow I
could make this RL become
infinity?
OK, so in this case,
output VO would be low.
OK, I get many benefits by
doing this.
One benefit is that,
look, I have opened this switch
here so I don't have any standby
current.
OK, the standby current is
zero.
The second benefit is that my
output gets dragged down to
ground, OK?
Out here, my output was VS
multiplied by RON divided by the
sum of these two.
Out here, I have a direct
connection to ground,
and nothing to the power
supply, VS, and so therefore I
have a nice, solid low.
So the question is that,
can I get this situation?
OK, that is a key insight.
So, imagine that somehow,
when this was high,
I could get this to open up,
much like when this was low,
I got this to open up.
OK, so think about it.
So, the intuition is that what
I need instead of a resistor
here, what if I have something
like the MOSFET that I have
here?
So, I have a MOSFET here that
turned off when VIN was low.
OK, what if I did the
complementary thing?
What if I put in some kind of
MOSFET here that would turn off
when VIN was high?
OK, so, much like the MOSFET
turned off when VIN was low down
here, imagine if I could find a
device that could turn off when
VIN was high?
OK, this would be on,
but this would be off.
So the behavior of this device
would have to be complementary
to this device.
So, we need some sort of a
switch to introduce this new,
little MOSFET device with
slightly different properties,
let me quickly review for you
the properties of the MOSFET
that we know about,
so our N channel MOSFET,
also called the NFET,
this is what we've been seeing
all this while,
is drawn like this.
I have a gate;
I have a drain;
I have a source.
And this guy is on when VGS is
greater than or equal to VT,
OK, and off when VGS is less
than VT.
You saw this before,
OK, nothing new here.
So, what I need is a device
that behaves in a complementary
manner.
OK, so the device is a P
channel MOSFET.
By the way, I must point out,
till about 1983-84 until the
early '80s, that's exactly
pretty much how chips were
designed, OK,
using an NFET for the switch
looking down here,
and a variety of different
kinds of devices to be used as
resistors.
OK, that's when technology
began moving towards this new
kind of technology I'm going to
talk about, and that
dramatically reducing the power
consumed.
And, the P channel MOSFET was
created, and this guy's called
the PFET.
It's a complementary device
that looks as follows.
OK, the difference here is
that, to show this is
complementary,
I'll put a little circle here.
It has a gate.
Just to make things a little
clearer, flip the drain and
source terminals,
and this guy is on at a
distinguished threshold voltage
of this with the NFET device,
let me put an N here to say
that this is the VT for the N
channel device.
And for this guy,
this guy came on when VGS was
greater than some voltage.
So, VTN could be,
for example,
one volt.
So, VGS was more than one.
This turned on.
In this case,
I wanted this to turn on when
VGS is some value which is lower
than, or much lower than,
the source voltage.
OK, so this guy turns on when
the gate voltage is higher.
This guy should turn on when
the gate voltage is
significantly lower than the
source voltage,
just the complementary
behavior.
OK, so when VGS is less than or
equal to VTP.
And in this case,
the threshold voltage for the
PMOS device, say,
just as an example,
maybe -1V.
So this means that if the
source is at,
say, 5V, OK,
then this device would turn on
if the gate, for example,
using that example was less
than 4V.
So, this is five.
If the gate fell below 4V,
this guy would turn on.
In this situation,
remember, if this was at zero,
the gate would have to be
greater than 1V to turn on.
In this situation,
the gate has to be less than 4V
if the source was at five to
turn on.
And, it's off.
OK, so this is a complementary
device that I postulate that
behaves in a complementary
manner.
So, the gate voltage rises,
this guy turns on,
and in this situation,
when the gate voltage drops
below the source voltage,
this guy turns on.
OK, so when there's a rising
guy that turns on in this
particular situation when it
falls, the gate turns on and
shows some resistance.
In this case,
the resistance would be RON.
And to show that it's N
channel, let me say N.
And in this case,
the resistance,
when it turns on,
would be RONp to represent P
channel.
OK, so now consider the
following circuit for the
inverter.
So, instead of my resistor,
I put a complementary device,
OK, and that's it.
So all I've done here is
replace my resistor with a
MOSFET that behaves
complementary to the N channel
MOSFET.
So this is my gate,
my drain.
This is my source,
my gate, my source,
and my drain.
OK, and this guy is called a
pull up, and this guy is called
a pull down.
OK, and the reason is that this
guy pulls the output to ground
when it's turned on,
while this guy,
when switched on,
will pull this node up to VS.
So, I pull it down or pull it
up based on when the VIN is high
or low.
So, let's look at the two
situations.
So, let's say,
as an example,
my VS is 5V,
and let's say VIN in one
situation being 5V,
and another situation being
equal to 0V.
Let's draw the equivalent
circuit in both these cases.
So, when VIN is high,
I have my usual circuit.
When VIN is high,
this MOSFET,
as before, when VIN is 5V,
the N channel MOSFET below is
turned on, and so I have an RON
resistance here.
But remember,
VIN is 5, and VS is 5V,
then the voltage across the
source and the gate of this P
channel FET is now equal,
five and five.
OK, so this one would turn off.
And that's the circuit that I
get.
The output is suitably low.
In this situation,
if VIN is zero,
what happens in this situation?
Here's my output.
If VIN is 0V,
the lower device turns off.
This is zero.
This guy turns off,
and that's the situation for
the N channel MOSFET.
How about this guy here?
What happens here?
This is at 5.
So let me just,
this is at 5V.
OK, and VIN is at 0V.
OK, so therefore,
the GS of this is -5V.
If this is zero and this is
five, G, source,
and drain, GS is -5V,
and -5V is significantly less
than the threshold -1V in our
example.
So, this one will switch on.
And if this one switches on,
what I end up getting is RONp
out there.
So, when this one kicks in,
it pulls the output high and VO
goes high.
So, all I've done is replaced
my resistor with a complementary
device, which switches off when
the input is high,
and switches on when the input
is low.
And the beauty of this is that
at no point, assuming all the
devices are ideal here,
at no point do I have a short
circuit between the output,
do I have a current path from
the output to the ground from
the supply to ground,
OK, I have this turned off or
this turned off.
So, this type of logic
involving a PMOS transistor
here, and the N channel
transistor here is called CMOS
logic for, OK,
it's called complementary MOS
logic.
That's what CMOS comes from.
OK, so I'm sure you've read in
a number of places that most
digital chips today use CMOS
technology.
It comes from complementary
MOS, and complementary comes
from the use of complementary
transistors: N channel,
P channel, turns on when high,
turns off when high,
turns off when low,
turns on when low.
OK, that's exactly
complementary to each other.
OK, so what you've seen here
has been the workhorse of the
digital industry for the past
two decades, 20 years,
CMOS logic.
OK, and even the most advanced
chip from Intel has an inverter
that looks exactly like that.
OK, if you count all the
inverters in the universe today,
I would say a significant
fraction of those look exactly
like that, no difference,
just so simple.
So, the key with something like
that is there is no path from
the power supply to the ground,
and so by that model,
I did not consume any standby
power.
OK, my standby power in that
idealized model is zero.
So, let's compute P.
So, what is P dynamic?
Let's use the method that we
adopted in the last lecture,
and draw the equivalent
circuit, and compute the power.
OK, so I'm going to model the
following situation,
and assume that I drive a
capacitive load,
C.
OK, and as an input,
as I did the last time,
I'm going to assume I have some
input voltage,
VIN, that looks like this.
The cycle time,
T, and the frequency is 1/t,
and let me assume that this is
T1, and this is T2.
OK, and I'm assuming that T1
and T2 are both much larger than
the respective time constants.
OK, the time constants when,
for discharging here,
is C RONn, and here the
relevant resistance is RONp.
The charging time constant is
RONp times C.
OK, so T1 and T2 are assumed to
be much greater than these two.
So when you look at this,
there's one other benefit
besides the power benefit,
OK, of using CMOS logic
compared to using NMOS.
OK, it not only cuts out my
standby power,
but there is another
significant advantage which is
almost equal to the power
advantage of this kind of CMOS
technology.
Anybody have any ideas?
What's the advantage?
What does intuition tell you?
Is CMOS going to be faster or
slower than NMOS?
Why?
That's right.
The key here is that the NMOS
design I showed you earlier was
relatively slow because it took
me a while to charge up the load
capacitor from RL.
In this situation,
RL will become really,
really small;
it's RONp.
It's roughly the same magnitude
as RONm.
OK, if so both of these on
resistances are more or less
equal and small,
then the rise time will be of
the same order of magnitude as
the fall time,
which makes this much faster
than the NMOS.
In NMOS, my time constant was
RLC, and RL was pretty large.
In this case it's RONp C,
and RONp can be made to be very
small because when it's switched
off, the resistance here is
infinity.
So, in this situation,
if I assume T1 and T2 are much
larger than the respective time
constants, I can go ahead and
draw my equivalent circuit.
So, here's VS.
So, for charging up,
let's say this one is going to
a one, or to a high.
So, I have VS going through a
resistor, RONp,
to a capacitor,
and this thing is a switch.
So I have RONp,
an ideal switch,
going to a capacitor,
C, this is my V out node,
OK, so it's VS going through a
resistance, RONp,
an ideal switch,
to a capacitor,
C.
That's a charging circuit.
For discharging,
I have C, discharging through
an ideal switch with RONn.
So, this situation,
I have an ideal switch,
RONn.
OK, so that's the equivalent
circuit for something like this.
So, in this circuit,
during T1, this guy's off,
and this guy's on,
on during T1,
and off otherwise.
This guy is on during T2,
OK, so just imagine,
this guy switches on,
this guy switches off,
OK?
And remember,
this is exactly the circuit I
had analyzed last time in the
last lecture,
and the result given by v
double asterisk.
And that result was simply
average power being CVS^2f.
That's the exact circuit we
used to compute the dynamic
power, CVS^2f.
OK, so we're done.
And how did this come about?
This came about because the
intuition here is that I'm
charging up the capacitor fully,
and then I'm discharging the
capacitor through this other
side, OK, and I'm consuming
power, dissipating power,
in these two resistances during
charge up and during the
discharge.
Half the power gets consumed
during charge up,
and half during the discharge.
So, I'd like to go back to
doing a few numbers here,
and taking a look at how,
even with this expression,
life can get pretty thorny as
we go ahead into the next
decade.
OK, so for our previous
example, we assumed that 10^8
gates, F=1 GHz,
C=0.1 femtofarads,
VS was 5V, and I don't need RL
anymore.
OK, why is it that I don't have
any resistance component here?
I don't have it here because
the power consumed by this
circuit is independent of those
resistances, provided T1 and T2
are long enough,
are much longer than the two
time constants,
RONp C, and RONn C.
OK, so I don't have RL in my
equation anymore.
I don't have any standby power.
So, based on this calculation,
the calculation I did up there
showed that I had 2.5 microwatts
per gate, and for 10^8 gates I
had 250W for a chip with 10^8
gates.
So, I'd like to dwell on this,
if you can move over to page
eight in your notes,
here.
Let me dwell on this for some
time, and pontificate on a few
things.
First of all,
this number,
as I said before,
is high, but not a disaster.
OK, so you can't use this in
laptops, but it's quite OK for a
desktop or a server,
and so on.
If you just go and put your ear
to a pedestal computer,
you'll always hear it making a
sound, and that sound is because
of a big fan that's inside it.
And, if you have a big enough
fan, 250W is not such a big
deal.
But, this is certainly a real
problem for mobile devices.
For a laptop,
this is unthinkable.
OK, so we have to deal with
this.
The second issue is the
following, that it's 250W for
1GHz.
Now, the fastest Pentium 4s
that money can by today are,
what, how many GHz?
What's the fastest Pentium 4
you can buy today?
What's that?
Does anybody have a 4GHz
Pentium 4 here?
Oh, darn, you beat me.
Anybody have a 3?
3GHz?
A couple.
So, I have a couple of 3GHz
machines, and our lab has a
whole ton of them.
So, if Intel comes out with
4GHz machines today,
they've been going up by about
1GHz roughly every year for the
past couple of years.
And, within three or four
years, you're going to see
chips, microprocessors that are
in the 5-10GHz range,
OK, assuming that all other
things stay equal,
which of course they're not,
but just to give you some
insight here,
if I clock these guys and build
circuits that are ten times
faster, I very soon go up to
2.5kW, again as I said,
all things being equal which
they're not.
But just to give you a sense,
as I increase my frequency,
so does the power consumed by
the chip, OK?
So, I really have to do
something here.
So, if I stare at this
equation, CVS^2f,
I want to increase f because
people will buy computers if I
have higher frequencies.
And, Intel has managed to use
its marketing campaigns to
pretty much convince consumers
that high frequencies are a good
thing.
OK, and whether they really
mean anything or not,
that's a different issue.
So, we've got this huge power
for assuming 5V,
OK, so it turns out that
microprocessors,
as they come out,
newer and newer versions run at
lower and lower voltages.
OK, they invent technologies
that use lower and lower
voltages, and go from VS 5V to,
today, VS on the order of 1.5
to 1V, somewhere in that range.
So the moment you do that,
you get a 25x reduction in
power.
OK, so in going from 2.5kW,
you would now come down to
something on the order of 100W,
which is, again,
much more reasonable,
again, all other things being
equal.
It turns out that the
capacitance of devices also
changes as you go to smaller and
smaller devices.
And, 100W is also pretty high,
and still not good enough for
mobile computers.
So, there are many,
many other tricks that people
use to get even lower powers.
One trick is to play games with
the clock.
OK, what you do is,
let's say for example in some
computation you are not going to
be using your floating point
unit.
Or let's say I'm going to be
using your integer adder unit.
OK, so what you can do is you
can turn off the clock to those
devices so that those devices do
not even switch when they're not
working.
OK, if I turn off the clock to
a device, the device isn't even
going to switch,
it's just going to sit there in
limbo without consuming any
power.
It's equivalent to turning off
both transistors.
If you turn off both the PMOS
and NMOS somehow,
OK, it's not consuming any
power.
And by doing that,
you can further cut down the
power.
So, if you can idle some of
your function units,
it's called idling a function
unit, idle a function unit for,
let's say, half the time.
OK, you would cut down power by
another factor of two.
We can idle,
then, 75% of the time,
come down to 25W.
So, those are the classes of
tricks that people play.
I'm going to stop here and
allow the underground guide
folks to do the survey.
But, suffice it to say that the
power discussion that I've gone
through with you is a very high
level discussion as to the real
thing.
In real life,
what actually happens is that
there is a fair amount of
standby power even for CMOS
logic.
It turns out that although I
don't have a path from VS to
ground for my two transistors,
it turns out that there are
many leakage currents.
OK, currents leak through all
kinds of places through the
drain of the inverter,
and so on and so forth.
And so, there is some standby
power.
So, let me show you a quick
demo while, I guess,
the review handouts are going
around.
And this shows the temperature
of my CMOS inverter,
and as I increase the
frequency, you can just watch
the temperature go up,
and hopefully we'll blow this
transistor.
So, I'm increasing the
frequency as you can see on the
side here, and higher frequency
implies more power consumption,
more temperature,
OK, and hopefully you will see
some smoke coming out of,
OK, I think I blew the
inverter.
So, the output is gone.
So, it's at 110 degrees there,
and that blew it.
Sometimes we see smoke come
out, but I guess today is not
one of our lucky days.
OK, so let me stop here and
have the underground guide folks
go through the reviews.